le tourisme l'hôtellerie la restauration
mais aussi l'industrie des secteurs
impactés par cette crise sanitaire et
économique dans le département des
yvelines avec nous gérard bacheliers
bonjour bonjour président de la chambre
de commerce et d'industrie des yvelines
alors avec vous est ce qu'on peut faire
un point sur la situation économique
dans le département
un mois après le début du confinement la
situation économique dans le département
donc est toujours aussi compliqué bien
sûr où l'avait dire les restaurants
hôtels restent fermés donc je peux vous
donner quelques chiffres par rapport aux
autres chômage partiel à l'utilisation
des fonds de solidarité puisque nous
avons dix sept mille établissements donc
qui en demandait le chômage partiel qui
représente à peu près de 112 1722
salariés
c'est à peu près 50 % des établissements
de du des yvelines donc c'est quand même
à un point important avec bien sûr
restauration hôtellerie qui sont les
plus marquées et après bien sûr la
l'industrie la métallerie la
construction concernant le fonds de
solidarité vous l'avez évoqué il ya des
fonds dessous des fonds de solidarité 1
pour notamment les petites entreprises
les indépendants les commerçants ça
aussi c'est très utilisé par les acteurs
yvelinois c'est utiliser mais pas
suffisamment utilisé puisque il y a eu
donc 7200 paiement ce qui représente à
peu près pour une moyenne de 1350 euros
par part paiement et c'est largement
insuffisant au niveau de l'île de france
d'ailleurs par rapport à d'autres
régions
donc on incite largement les entreprises
qui peuvent y avoir droit à l'utiliser
d'autant plus que ce système de fonds de
solidarité va être un peu plus élargie
dans la loi de finances rectificative
qui est en discussion actuellement il ya
quand même des évolutions importantes
qui sont apportées justement à ce fonds
de solidarité
il faut vraiment que les entreprises
profite de cette de ceux de ce
dispositif sur la situation économique
aussi on peut parler malheureusement de
certaines défaillances d'entreprises ou
pas du tout c'est pas encore le cas pour
l'instant on n'a pas beaucoup d'éléments
sur les défaillances d'entreprises je
pense qu'on le verra après celle à la
crise sanitaire
par contre ce que l'on peut dire c'est
que il y a en tout cas les informations
que j'ai c'est qu'il ya déjà des
entreprises qui ont décidé d'arrêter
carrément donc l'icdi liquidations
directes sans procédure donc ça c'est un
élément quand même important ça veut
dire qu'on a qui baissent les bras et
qui abandonnent
et puis depuis le début de la crise vous
avez bien en place une plateforme
téléphonique d'urgence pour les
entreprises est ce que vous avez mis
depuis d'autres dispositifs en place
oui alors cette plateforme a reçu dix
sept mille sollicitations et nous avons
mis deux deux outils supplémentaires
c'est une plateforme qui s'appelle cci
entraide qui permet justement des
échanges de solidarité et de
complémentarité entre entreprises dont
les entreprises peuvent faire des offres
où certains recherchent des produits
donc ça permet justement d'avoir des
échanges solidaires entre entreprises
dans cette situation difficile mais ça
peut je pense perdurer par la suite et
je l'espère il ya aussi donc une autre
bâton comme a mis en place ce qui
s'appelle les commerces à domicile qui
permet justement de référence et les
commerces qui ont mis en place des
livraisons à domicile et donc cette
ville dans les yvelines donc ont choisi
ce système c'est poissy mantes la jolie
les mureaux maurepas houdan camplong
sainte honorine andrésy voilà donc c'est
une plateforme qui permet justement
d'aider les commerces de centre-ville
dans leur livraison à domicile un
dernier mot gérard bacheliers le
président de la république emmanuel
macron a annoncé à un début de
déconfinement à partir du 11 mai
prochain comment vous imaginez cette
relance économique
et est-ce qu'il va pas avoir
on va pas constaté une rupture avec
l'ancien modèle économique d'avant crise
oui cette relance elle va être
progressive à être progressif tout
simplement parce qu'il ya quelques
dirait filière qui vont démarrer comme
le bâtiment et les travaux publics qui
vont démarrer assez vite avant la fin du
mois d'avril
mais bon les difficultés qui vient voir
bien sûr ces deux d'avoir tous les
éléments sanitaires nécessaires pour
justement permettre à ces entreprises de
travailler c'est-à-dire des masques des
blues tout ce qui est nécessaire
et puis une nouvelle organisation du
travail aussi pour les entreprises du
bâtiment et des travaux publics ce qui
va justement créé un surcoût pour ces
entreprises et ce surcoût va se
retrouver bien sûr dans leurs devis et
dans leurs propositions
c'est évident donc c'est un surcoût qui
va être nécessaire et d'autres
entreprises repartent comme les
jardineries actuellement dans qui
repartaient il faut savoir que les
jardineries c'est entre mars et juin qui
ils font le maximum de leur chiffre
d'affaires
mais bien sûr par la suite j'irai à plus
long terme qu'il faut penser à une
relocalisation un autre modèle de
fonctionnement de l'industrie de
l'économie sur nos territoires
il faut profiter justement de ce qui
s'est passé jusqu'à maintenant c'est à
dire de la livraison à domicile des
circuits courts d'une utilisation un peu
plus importante de tout ce qui est de
tout le numérique donc et ça il faut il
faut que ça dure je pense qu'il faut que
ça continue et aussi des bons exemples
de solidarité entre entreprises puisque
on voit que air liquide renault peugeot
et valeo travailler ensemble pour les
pour les respirateurs mais aussi
d'autres entreprises profitent de cette
phase pour aider justement le public et
pour dire et renouveler un petit peu
leur leur façon de fonctionner donc
j'espère que cette solidarité grandes
entreprises petites entreprises va durer
sur le territoire qu'on aura un peu plus
de sous traitants locaux
et puis aussi que tout ce qui est lié
aux circuits courts va perdurer
la suite merci gérard bacheliers pour ce
décryptage vous en prie président de la
chambre de commerce et d'industrie des
yvelines